hey what's up my name's samuel leaves on
this video you're going to be learning
about rent to rent buy refurbished
refinance and how to become financially
free i'm going to be picking the brains
of mother and son duo that have become
financially free through being creative
in property
and you're going to learn exactly how
they did it and how you can too so if
you enjoy my channel do me a favor hit
the like button if you've got questions
about this interview drop your comment
and questions below we'll do our best to
answer so firstly priti and carl thank
you so much for coming down to my house
thank you great yes thanks for having me
so you've been working super hard why
don't you tell me about your back story
how you guys decided to team up and why
you wanted to get into property in the
first place great stuff kyle do you want
to go yes so um
it was around when i was 16. i knew i
wanted to get into property and
i know my mum's always done it uh when
she was younger before she had me and
i've always kind of watched like grind
his eyes homes on the hand and stuff
like with her and
we knew we wanted to get into it we just
didn't know how we always thought it was
it required a lot of money um which is
when she discovered you and we got got
it off from there then
all right so your background then
property what's your sort of back story
i used to help a friend who was buying
rental properties and she loved the way
i'd done my houses and particularly on a
shoestring and she said this is what i
want you to do i want you to do exactly
what you've done in your house do it on
a shoestring in my rental properties and
she paid me she paid me to go shopping
to stage a house i absolutely loved it
and then i was pregnant with kyle and i
stopped doing all of that
um i always thought getting into
properties you had to do it the
conventional way you had to save lots of
money
and so like carl said when he got to a
certain age he said mom i want to do
properties with you and i said well kyle
we need to have some money first
um get yourself a trade because at least
you can do
some of the work yourself so hence kyle
got into plumbing he's just
in the process of finishing his plumbing
apprenticeship now
um but i still thought how can we do
this without money so i bought one
single layer and i'd done it by
refinancing my own residential property
so um
i you know i was i was thinking that was
the only way and then um
i guess it was it was just something
that happened out of the blue so i'd
gone into
the hospital for a very minor operation
and and it was mine it was supposed to
be
30 minutes and then i was leaving
straight after
and the
procedure went horribly wrong
and i ended up being taken in for
emergency surgery a four-hour operation
um major surgery apparently with this
operation there's 25 mortality rate
um intensive care
and that was it i was out of action for
three months i was at home for three
months
and i got to thinking that you know the
children i'm a single parent
uh and i know they're not they're not
babies but what if something happened
you know
um
and you know about the financial side of
things neither of them were working
full-time
and i knew kyle always wanted to get
into property so i thought let me just
start doing a bit of research it was
like the first time that i'd literally
had some headspace some time to sit and
think about how i can do properties
um so i was trawling through the
internet came across yourself i watched
a couple of winners on a wednesday and i
thought i love this
and then underneath you know you can go
on to this crash course for a pound so i
said to kyle we definitely have to do
this
starting no brainer no brainer started
telling my partner he's like i'll go
told my daughter her boyfriend five of
us we all came and it was at the time
when you used to do two-day crash
courses
we were absolutely buzzing both both
nights you know after the event we're
like this is the best thing we've ever
done
um so all five of us signed up to the
training
i remember coming up to you guys
and
doing a picture and shooting a video and
just saying you guys are going to blow
up in property you know watch this space
folks these guys are going to do big
things and since then you have you've
come on to become financially free and
you've secured no money down deals and
you've literally done everything
step by step from the training and it's
worked beautifully so why don't you tell
me about after joining the training you
registered onto the academy which is
incredible um
what what happened next and this was
just before lockdown so it was it was
really interesting times we had to pause
everybody's academy membership then we
put everything online while we were
waiting to come back to do live events
so it's a really weird time why don't
you talk us through like how the
training was and maybe what your first
deal was and what happened
yeah okay so yeah the first training
course we went on so it was french rent
because through lockdown so we'd been to
the crash course um and we thought that
was the route didn't we rent to rent um
and so we had the choice of which one we
were going on because lockdown happened
in between and then you opened up again
for live events
and so we decided to go for entering
because we've just been doing
research through the lockdown
um and then we went on to the training
didn't we yeah yeah
i think it was november
2020 we went and it was
then we signed on to the academy after
but then everything got shut down and we
were in a situation like how do we go
about it and stuff like that i mean we
were constantly logging into the
webinar calls that he did every week we
were seeing everyone's success and how
everyone was getting it and we just
couldn't at first it took i think it
took about three months did it to get
our first one yeah but involved was i
say it took a lot of hard work and there
were times where we felt down like are
we ever going to do this is it right for
us but like i said we just stayed
persistent with it and we eventually got
the first one which is which is great so
and when you were working on getting
that first one you were also you was
you're studying full-time in college
right learning trying to try and become
a plumber yeah you're working as what
was your job at the time i'm civil
servant right and what were you doing
exactly um i manage services in the
civil service i look after services in
the buildings that civil servants work
in how did you manage to juggle your
time between studying working full-time
as a civil servant and then also trying
to get a rent to rent yeah it was really
difficult um we kind of started it sort
of after five every day we'd switch the
laptops on go through training ourselves
because it was online because of the
lockdown as well so we started doing the
online training every night probably an
hour or two
and then you started drinking agents
didn't you well at first i remember
before doing any of the training i
actually didn't really have a lot of
confidence at all to be honest with you
i had a lot of self-limiting beliefs and
stuff like i didn't think it was right
for me at first it's the same when i did
plumbing i thought
is this for me or not and that's how i
felt about property at first but
obviously go into your event being
around like-minded people it really
helped and it built my confidence up as
well so i did an event as well called um
tell the world which you know about as
well which definitely helped build my
confidence on a personal level as well
but um yeah i remember just
attempting to ring agents and it lasted
around 10 seconds before putting the
phone down and i just thought is this
really for me but yeah in the end i just
stayed consistent with it and
here we are now now when you got your
first rent to rent we will get to the
good later i promise but but but it was
a disaster because well tell me what
happened
yeah it was we spent so long doing it up
so the first thing to say was we um
we did negotiate um a rent-free period a
grace period the house was so run down
um and so
we realized this afterwards but we we
negotiated the rent-free period but
instead of just renting out rooms
individually we waited until they were
all done up that was the first thing
first mistake because where was it
leicester right so what we did was um we
carried on past the rent free period
still doing the the other rooms up
meaning that we ended up paying another
month's rent without anyone in the house
so that was the first mistake wasn't it
kyle
yeah there was a lot of mistakes i think
because it was a lot of work involved as
well we identified that really maybe it
should have possibly got other tradesmen
in like painters for example as um that
took a majority of the time we
ended up running past the six-week grace
period
just solely from painting and decorating
because it needed a lot of work but i
think what we did do and like what you
say as well in training is utilize your
network um we got our family family and
friends around to come and help every
day which was which was like i said it
was good of them we which got it we got
it done quicker than yeah than just the
two of us
um
but yeah in the end we ran past
now i always say on the academy there's
only two reasons why you can fail one
reason is because you don't take any
action and the second reason is because
when you get stuck you don't ask for
help you guys did ask for help
on the mastermind tell us what happened
so basically after we'd done all that
hard work and then we were ready to to
um get it tenanted
i mean the house looked beautiful and
yet we'd have people around
show them all seven rooms
um and they'd be like oh when they saw
the first room oh wow that's amazing
it's like amazing going up three three
story house
and then they say right okay and i i
remember from your training um that you
said that you should always secure it at
the point that they come
um to view the property so this is what
i'd said to them before they come um can
you bring a deposit with you a holding
fee we'll carry out some checks bring
some id for some reason they all said
well um at the moment can i just think
about it i want to just go and i
like we didn't know what to do so they'd
just go and then there was a must you
have your
monday mastermind calls which we
absolutely love because the times when
we're feeling really
low and we think we're gonna do this we
get on the call and everyone is winning
or you know sharing problems and helping
us out so i just piped up and i said
samuel i'm having a real problem i said
i'm not sleeping and i really wasn't
sleeping we'd already paid one month's
rent
uh out of our own pockets um and it
wasn't tenanted and i thought
you know the rent's 2200 a month i can't
keep doing this where am i going to get
the money from so i just i just
shouted up on the mastermind call and
you said to me
what can i do to help
and i really appreciated that
and i said i'd love it if you would just
come and just tell me what i'm doing
wrong i don't know what i'm doing wrong
and it was great because not only did
you come the people on the network as
well were all offering me advice texting
me send me photographs tell me what
you've put in your advert
and like you always say your network is
your net worth and it's so true
but the more that we are in this network
the more we're learning the more support
we're getting and the more we're being
motivated it's amazing but
yeah you came round and you gave us some
great advice just schoolboy errors that
we were making um weren't we kyle so and
it was great coming down and seeing it
as well but when i came down as well we
actually got a tenant there and then
didn't we
to move in and we did a whole separate
video about how to fill your rooms fast
so you stop showing everybody all the
rooms show them one at a time block
viewings refresh the ad there was a
whole bunch of stuff that we we
implemented so
how's that property now i know you've
got lots of other properties since then
that first one you're paying 2 200 to
the landlord obviously it's been a year
or so now what happened next how's that
property still doing today it's fully
fully occupied now we're making 1200
clean profit a month incredible yeah so
i say we don't struggle at all obviously
since you coming around and helping us
it's just it's been easy to get tenants
in we use obviously use different kind
of platforms spare room the obvious
facebook marketplace gumtree loads of
different ways to to get them in open
rent so we make we still make sure the
adverts still live now because
in case we have other opportunities yeah
i can then show them our other rent to
rent that we've got which is which is
what i recommend for anyone brilliant so
that one property now 1200 pounds amount
of profit you had a grace-free period
you did put some elbow grease and paint
into doing up but that's a i mean that's
that's like halfway there towards
replacing a full-time income and i know
since then you've gone on to get more
rents and rents and and um you're also
working on brrs how are the other deals
going what's happening at the moment
yeah it's it's it's crazy um it's so
we've got a couple more entrants and
more in the pipeline
and one of the things that you talk
about in your training is
a lot about mindset
and
something that's really kind of like
helped to help just to sort of just
get off the ground really quickly all of
a sudden
is just changing the way we think about
things and one of the things you talk
about in your training
is your your financial thermostat
and we've been listening to oh we've
both been listening to this book um bob
proctor's book change your paradigm
change your life
and he talks a lot about
the same things that you talk about in
your training the financial thermostat
where people think
that even when so so maybe they're in in
a job and they're earning a lot of money
and then they become an entrepreneur
they still stop at the the same salary
that they were on in job because they've
not changed the financial thermostat and
you talk about that um when you do the
financial freedom intensive we talk
about
where we want to be i love that training
so much because it just changes the way
you think about things
and that's really helped us change our
mindset so
one of the things that we've been doing
is literally just going in to estate
agents at one time i used to think
estate agents were my enemy they're not
if you can build good rapport with an
estate agent they are feeding you deals
and that's all of a sudden we're getting
phone calls they're saying this i've got
another one do you want to take this off
do you want to take these softwares they
approach yours don't they now that's
it's like say
they've got a no-like and trust you yeah
and
it's more easier for them to do that if
they can see you face-to-face they're
more inclined to say yes
to your face than know over the phone
yeah which is why we think that is and
also your first deal is always your
hardest so that first deal for you you
learned from that i mean tell me about
your second deal where where was your
second rental i was in the leicester as
well yeah so it's actually two minutes
away from the first one right that's a
six bedroom two bathroom that's bringing
in a thousand a month profit yeah wow
yeah so i'm kind of overseeing that one
um my mum's doing the first one how does
it feel though to be in a situation
whereby you're studying at the moment to
learn to be a plumber yeah but actually
i don't know whether you'll be a plumber
or not
it's hard i'm still trying to balance it
like structure and organization is
something i'm working on at the minute
obviously i'm still stuck in that rat
race nine to five kind of job but i'm
still i'm trying to make sure and commit
a bit more property because i know i
want to go into that full time yeah so
i'm just making sure you don't need to
have presumably you don't need to have a
job no no and that's that's the beauty
of it so so so what do you reckon the
next year looks like for you because
when you finish you call it college yeah
what are you going to do
i'm i'm going to go full time and
obviously i think that's that's the way
forward i've always wanted to do that
anyway yeah i just thought
it's good to have that background
knowledge of the plumbing side i've i
said i've built a network of tradesmen
my friends are all builders you know i'm
well connected in that side and i think
what works well with me and my mum is
that i know the the hands-on side of it
um and she's got the business side of it
so two heads are better than one right
and that's what i say tell me about your
brr deal that you're buying as well so
like i say you say utilize your network
i actually used to work in an estate
agents when i was 16. i was doing it
like every two weeks just like answering
calls just getting to know the market
and stuff like that and the agent who's
actually passed this deal he actually
lives on my street we've known him for
15 years now and you say tell everyone
what you're doing yeah and see exactly
what i did and he gave me this it's a
probate property off market i've managed
to get it 45k below market value what's
the purchase price uh 480. so you're
buying it for 480 how on earth are you
getting the money to buy that
well that's a good question so yeah um
me and my partner are
part funding it but then something else
happened this is what's been happening
in our life it's been crazy but i was
invited onto the show property elevator
and um so it's a dragon's den style show
for prop with property investors um that
would potentially prepare to fund your
deals so to go on to this show
i got some help from your mentors
because there's been been an academy
member we've got access to mentors
so tony crook spent a whole hour with me
going through the pitch what to talk
about
and it was amazing because i felt so
prepared
i was so nervous at first went in
five investors there and they grill you
they really do grill you um but i was
able to talk about this deal with the
help that i'd had from tony
and
every question they fired at me had an
answer and they actually commented on
that they said well you know you did a
really good pitch
so they were really impressed with that
and they also said that even though
you know some of them weren't investing
in that deal that they really liked me
and they would like to work with me in
the future
so i thought that was amazing but i
managed to secure two investors
um and so they both agreed that they
would go 50 50.
yeah
right that's incredible so basically
you've managed to pitch the deal and get
some exposure on a show you put in a
little bit of your own money yeah and
you're buying it for 480. so what the
figures what's the what's the refurb
cost so it's 130 but we're going to do
20k added just for legals and everything
like that so total money in is 6 30.
yeah so currently it's in an article
area but obviously having the help of
your mum she guided me on turning into
self-contained flats yeah so
we're looking to be able to pull all of
our money out by the end of the deal
what do you think the end value will be
uh around 8 40. wow yeah yeah huge
you must be so proud as well of kyle
because
you know and you've obviously helped him
a lot but he's also put a lot of work in
himself and you guys have been like a
duo power team working mother and son
team but you must be super proud of him
the fact that now he never will have to
work a normal job because he's set up
for life absolutely and i'm it's all i
ever wanted you know i
i knew
um i was going to say the error of my
ways but you know i didn't know what i
know now and i'm so glad that he knows
now from a young age i wish i knew when
i was like but i know now and that is
the path that i wanted him to take
my daughter's doing something similar as
well and that's that's exactly what i
wanted for my children to be
entrepreneurs to not have the 95 being
the rat race
and i am i am super proud and um the brr
carl has done all the research himself
um you know he's used your mentorship um
he managed to speak to your mum who
gives some really good advice because we
were stuck at one point because this
house has not got um
it's not got hmo license there was a a
92 year old lady that lived in this
huge seven bedroom house all on her own
um but it's article four it's a
conservation area we're thinking how do
we get over this what do we do
um and then through carl um speaking to
to sue
uh she advised him on on self-contained
flats which we hadn't even thought about
you know title splitting self-contained
uh and actually it's worth more it's
worth more doing it that way you know
what as well is really interesting
no one that's successful in business has
done it alone
and
everybody is where they are because of
other people that have helped them along
the way so i've been helped by my mom
and i've been helped by my mentors
you've been helped by
for the academy and by tony and my mom
and me and the the elevator pitch guys
that are funny like it's just about put
put in investing in yourself and then
other people will then invest in you
if you weren't invested in yourself
probably the elevator boys wouldn't have
invested in your deal because you
wouldn't know what you're talking about
it when you invest in yourself and step
out if you haven't invested in yourself
kyle and then your mom probably wouldn't
have helped fund part of your d so it's
it's about bet on yourself and then
others will bet on you and and ask for
help yeah it's so true and it's funny
because
before we arrived this morning we said
exactly the same like at one time if if
i you know
saw anything like a training program i
thought i'm not paying for that one you
know i need to put that money to to some
use somewhere i can't spend that money
on myself i'd almost didn't value myself
enough
um and it's really strange because you
know when i speak to to friends that
aren't doing something similar you know
they they say wow you spent you spent
that money on training
and then i go on to say well you spent
40 000 on your university education
where are you
you know yeah and this is a fraction
and look at where i am look at what
we're doing and this is just the start
yeah so if you want people to invest in
you you first got to invest in yourself
you've got to add more value to yourself
yeah that's that's the way of business
so right was it hard was it a hard
decision though like joining the academy
or for me personally at first it was
obviously
i've saved my apprentice from my
apprenticeship i didn't really get a lot
of money from apprenticeship and i was
putting money aside and initially it was
going to be for
for a help to buy that was i didn't know
anything we were going to put it all
together and then when the academy when
we got off the academy i was up
it's quite a bit of money but obviously
me no that's on my thermostat was a lot
lower then but then
think of it now i'm so glad i've done it
because look where i am now i'm a
completely different person yeah so
you make it back a triple quadruple and
more but it's like if you don't know
you you'll just never know and you'll
carry on doing the conventional way and
it's funny now because i look at people
that are sort of trying to do things and
doing them the conventional way
and i just think you don't you don't
realize what's out there yeah you know
once you've got the education
there's so much to be gained it's
absolutely it's mind-blowing yeah it's
like once you know you can't unknow yeah
yeah it's been so good working with you
guys and i know you've had a lot of
input not just for me but also from the
whole team alistair tony
everybody and that's what it's about
this is a this is a community and also
you're not just investing in education
you're also investing in not just what
you know but also who you know it's the
power of network and like you said when
you reached out to me on the mastermind
yes i came to your house to help you out
but you had you had dozens of people and
the great thing is now
on the academy when people are
struggling to rent the rooms out and
they're stuck like for instance um
karina was struggling
you then reached out and helped her yes
and it's such a joy to be able to when
you reach the top i know you're not at
the top per side but as you rise to pull
other people up with you it's just it's
such a beautiful thing and it's been an
honor to be able to mentor you
what would be your advice to someone
watching this that's thinking i want to
follow in the footsteps and do the same
i mean i would say 100
always invest in yourself
value yourself invest in yourself
there's so much more to be gained
um
you you wouldn't you don't even realize
the world is your oyster
just spend some money on yourself some
time on yourself and be kind to yourself
so important and the other thing is
i always say
give value first serve first and success
follows yeah love that love that what
about you kyle if you were giving advice
to someone that was just starting out in
property how old are you 23 now 23 yeah
if someone maybe who's in a similar
situation to you or if you're advising
yourself from two years ago what would
you say
just stick to it like work on yourself
your mindset's the key if you put
anything
you can put anything to it if you
believe it yeah
stay consistent stay persistent don't be
hard everyone's on their own journey
some people are harder than others but
as long as you stay consistent with
everything you're going to get you're
going to get there you've just got to
believe in yourself
that's so true and i've seen you know
your journey as well has been really
great to see your confidence and and i
just want to say as well thank you to
you both because not only have you come
to the academy and learned and took but
you've given so much more than you've
taken you've crewed events you've helped
so many people and you're just such a
joy to have worked with so i really
appreciate you and thanks for coming
down to my house to share thank you
thank you so much for having us it's
been amazing awesome so guys i hope you
found that educational and inspirational
um kyle and pretty smashing it in
property if you want to come and connect
with us and come down to the property
investors crash course like they did
then guess what you can come down for
free limited availability but i will
leave a link in the description where
you can come and meet me and be trained
at the property investors crash course
if you want to see more videos like this
where i'm interviewing people that are
financially free in property there's a
whole playlist right here if you want to
see pretty and kyle's leicester hmo and
you want to see how they filled it fast
then there's a video right here of the
three of us don't forget to subscribe
and we'll see you next time